bom dia é um prazer estar aqui no ted
falando para vocês hoje e eu vou falar
sobre a influência da internet
eu aposto que cada um de vocês têm um
celular no bolso porque hoje em dia é
muito difícil viver sem alguma coisa que
se conecta à internet e falando de
internet eu queria falar um pouco mais
sobre compartilhamento que é mandar e
compartilhar coisas um com os outros e
sempre tem aquela teoria de aqui com
sete pessoas você pode conhecer o mundo
inteiro mas eu queria compartilhar um
dado com vocês aqui eu sabia se cada um
de vocês compartilharem uma coisa com
seis pessoas e essas seis pessoas
compartilharem com mais 44 pessoas e
essas 44 pessoas compartilhem com mais
44 pessoas e tudo isso aconteceu e seis
vezes
tá eu sei que é um número muito grande
mas isso vai atingir 7 bilhões de
pessoas
isso é um número muito grande e eu fico
imaginando que dez anos atrás isso era
praticamente impossível você
compartilhar uma informação com esse
tanto de não tô falando que cá todo
mundo aqui compartilha coisa com esse
tanto de gente mas para você
compartilhar informação há dez anos
atrás era muito mais difícil do que hoje
e isso até me deixa um pouco feliz por
otávio
o envolvido nessa parte de tecnologia de
internet
bom ao contrário do compartilhamento
queria comentar um pouco também sobre a
privacidade com vocês que depois do caso
do adwords nolden isso venho entrando na
nossa mente com uma coisa para alguns
bom e para outras pessoas ruins e eu
queria falar minha opinião sobre isso
bom primeiramente eu acho que não tem
nenhum problema a gente entrar num site
de anúncios alguma coisa assim e quando
a gente entrar nas nossas redes sociais
o que você estava procurando
você vê que ficou mais barato não tem
nenhum problema e eu acho que isso é
super saudável na vida de internet hoje
em dia
mais recentemente um site entrou no ar
chamados tudo sobre todos vocês vocês
conhecem eu acho que alguns em outros
não mas é um site que permite que você
coloca um quando você coloca o nome
inteiro da pessoa aparece o número do
celular endereço cpf até quem são os
vizinhos da pessoas aparecem em sites
duvidam
pode entrar lá e tentar e eu acho que
isso é a parte que não é bom passar esse
ponto então eu acho que a privacidade é
bom até esse ponto isso é qualquer
pessoa pode entrar lá tudo bem o governo
tem esse dado alguma coisa mas vou a
qualquer pessoa e eu realmente fico
pensando se a gente chegou no nível que
é saudável para a privacidade e voltando
ao assunto de internet eu queria falar
de um assunto que está muito no momento
hoje em dia
chama economia e subjetiva não sei se
vocês conhecem mas o verde esporte fae e
ever be
todas essas empresas são categorizados
como economia e subjetiva e hoje eu
queria falar um pouco mais sobre as
empresas que acham que não vão ser
abaladas por essa economia que é um novo
tipo de economia diferente da
tradicional mas que eu acho que daqui a
algum tempo todo mundo vai ter que
entrar nesse tipo de economia
bom as coisas mudam e novos empregos são
formados e pessoas não vão exercendo
esses novos empregos
todos os empregos que a gente tem hoje
há 20 anos atrás eu aposto que metade
deles não resistiu
e esse bt é um novo tipo de emprego que
as pessoas estão começando a exercer que
chama business transformation officer
que a pessoa a quem ela entra na empresa
e ela ensina a empresa sair do ar e
entrar no z porque é o tipo de empresa é
o tipo é o jeito que a empresa precisa
seguir para continuar não será abalada
na economia do objetivo e a grande
desculpa que muitas empresas dão é que
elas falam que o segmento delas são
consolidados e elas não nunca vão ser
abaladas por esse tipo de economia como
bancos empresas de telecomunicação
mas hoje eu vou mostrar para vocês
porque eles estão errados
bom uma empresa da suíça fez uma
pesquisa chamada digital waltex que é
como se fosse um tornado e ela colocou
todos esses ramos da economia e no meio
quais que são as mais prováveis nos
próximos anos que serão modificados que
terão que sofrer mudanças elas não se
adaptarem neste novo tipo de economia
subjetiva e os bancos e as empresas de
telecomunicações por incrível que pareça
eles estão no meio desse vortex
e só pra contar um pouco sobre vocês os
bancos
apesar de toda a tecnologia que os
bancos brasileiros que são bastante
avançados é que eles investem na
tecnologia e não isso não representa
nenhum quinto do que os bancos dos
estados unidos e do reino unido
investiram juntos então só pra vocês
pensarem que às vezes vocês acham que a
está tudo certo meu banco está
consolidado tanto certo mas eles não
estão investindo o tanto que eles
precisam e na minha opinião eu acho que
isso vai ter que mudar algum dia nos
estados unidos e já tem vários startups
que se elas se dão autodenominam
desagregadores bancos que você entra na
startup como você não precisa mais
humano que eu sei que hoje ainda está um
pouco cedo para a gente começar tudo
isso mas eu te falar se há cinco anos
atrás para que você está lidando com um
táxi só pedi para o aplicativo você
nunca imagina que você poderia fazer
isso é muito mais fácil ligar cinco anos
atrás
alguns de vocês hoje agora liga para
pedir táxi aposto que não e 715 milhões
foi o valor que as empresas de
financiamento coletivo em 2014 e até o
meio de 2015 e investiram nessa nesse
novo tipo de economia e gente isso é
muito dinheiro muito dinheiro e agora
falam das telecomunicações
eu queria falar um fato muito
interessante para vocês elas novamente
vão precisar mudar porque por exemplo
você hoje em dia mandar sms ou você
mandou a top
então isso é uma coisa que as empresas
precisam realmente mudar
e falando em telecomunicação e mídia
digital o facebook hoje agora acho que
dia 1º de setembro e atingiu o valor de
mercado de 245 bilhões de dólares
eles têm idéia do tamanho então vou
mostrar pra vocês é maior do que a
telefônica a vodafone ea américa móvil
junto que são as três principais
empresas de empresas de telecomunicação
no mundo inteiro
você tem idéia o impacto que isso faz do
mundo então os aplicativos novamente são
coisas que queria voltar a falar pra
vocês que eu acho que as empresas
poderiam entrar em contato e faz
os aplicativos funcionário de uma forma
melhor porque por exemplo uma empresa de
telecomunicação ela prefere que você
usou a tap ou sms
claro que o sms porque ela ganhar
dinheiro em cima disso mas todo mundo
usou a top
então é uma outra forma de pensar
para você ter uma idéia a venda de
smartphones em 2010 foi de 10 milhões
para 2015 93 milhões
então cada dia mais as pessoas mudam ea
economia precisa mudar também a economia
do executivo é um novo jeito de pensar
em um novo jeito de você pedir um táxi
pelo aplicativo é o novo jeito de você
ouve música grátis e isso é uma coisa
que eu queria falar hoje para vocês qual
seria a solução conseguir a solução de
você mudar dessa economia tradicional de
você sair dessa coisa que vocês estão
acostumados e tentar experimentar coisas
novas eu acho que as empresas deveriam
por meio de apis ou por meio de
comunicar com esses aplicativos que todo
mundo usa por exemplo a tap e porque não
como agora as empresas já vêm fazendo
você não precisa mais pagar um plano de
internet para o whatsapp e falando de
internet de áudio uma mensagem de texto
ela da sua rede de plano mensal ela
consumir 10 k bytes uma foto sem
capacetes mais um minuto de vídeo que
todo mundo que filma pelo menos um
minuto ela com ele consome 12 mega então
as empresas precisam se adaptar às novas
economias dos objectivos e trazendo para
a nossa vida a economia se adaptando é a
nossa vida se adaptando
então por exemplo eu não tenho muita
história pra contar para vocês que eu só
tenho 15 anos muitos palestrantes aqui
tem muito muito mais idade que ele tem
várias histórias pra contar
mas se eu fosse contar o tanto de vezes
que eu mudei na minha vida eu passei o
dia inteiro que contando porque todo
mundo muda pelo menos uma vez
e todo dia a gente tem novas
experiências mas e aí você vai querer
mudar ou não obrigado